hello everyone and welcome to the first
game that ended in round five of the
2021 uh tata still chess tournament uh
it's nils grandelius versus the leader
of the candidates tournament maxime
vashila grav
uh it's uh quite uh quite the game and
quite a theoretical struggle so without
further ado let's
check out what happened here nils with
the white pieces opens with
e4 and if you remember niels was leading
the tournament up to a point when
he lost the game to hari krishna so
let's see uh why this game
is so interesting and of course we all
know how maxine replies to e4 he goes
for his sicilian we have c5
knight f3 d6 and the d4 so the open
sicilian uh
most likely will result in a night or
knight to f6 knight to c3
and ace x maxine goes for the knight of
variation of the sicilian
uh what he what he is most famous for
uh we have bishop to g5 by nils e6
and now f4 so this is all absolute main
line
and now queen to b6 trying to grab that
b dupont
and if you've ever studied the sicilian
or uh you know
anything you might have heard of the
poison pawn variation so here
black is saying i would very much like
to grab this pawn and more often than
not
white will allow this here uh niels goes
queen to d2 and he invites maxine to go
after the poison pawn
now why is the pawn poison some
sometimes the pawn or a piece can be
poisoned if
uh if it's not okay to capture and then
it's been a
debate for many many years whether it's
okay or not to capture this beauty pawn
but now
with the existence of chess engines uh
it is okay both
to capture and not capture the pawn so
here uh
queen captures on b2 is played and now
rook the b1
uh for those of you who were following
the channel when we were doing the bobby
fischer saga
uh you might remember that famous game
11 i think
between boris baskey and robert james
fisher
where fisher grabbed the the poison pawn
uh but then
spawsky tricked him he esposkey didn't
go for rook to b1 he went for knight to
b3 and in those days
uh when not so much theory was available
uh this was uh this was enough to trick
fisher and
grab a full point and this one we still
play today but
rook to b1 is considered the absolute
top move so this is what
niels goes for uh rook to b1 and now
queen to a3 and now f5 this
has all been seen before so nothing new
here we have
bishop to e7 and now captures on e6 we
have bishop captures and of course
knight captures on e6 f captures and the
bishop the c4 going after this pawn
and already you can see that it's quite
a difficult position to
play especially uh if you don't know
what you're doing for black
there's the e6 pawn that's hanging
there's the b7 pawn that's hanging
so what do you do here mexi of course
knows his way around uh
this variation very very well so he goes
knight b to d7 and this is
uh even uh uh still considered the
absolute top line
we have bishop captures on e6 and now
knight to c5
attacking the bishop defending the b7
pawn and
like i said this is women played before
and even maxine played it uh
he played it against fabiana corwana in
the norway chess 2019 where fabiano
uh went to bishop to c4 and fabi was
able to win this game
and of course most likely uh maxime
analyzed it very deeply and he was
prepared for bishop to c4
bishop to f5 is also a known move here
but what
neil played is bishop to b3 and this is
what neil's prepared especially for this
game
uh it's move 15 and already we have a
completely new uh position on the board
or a completely new game
so what is bishop to b3 well obviously
you don't go after the bishop if cactus
captures then the queen has to move and
you will also lose the b7 pawn
so here maxime said okay bishop to b3
i'm just going to continue developing
rook the c8 we have castles by niels
and now comes knight captures on b3 now
knight captures on b3 is okay because
queen to c5 will come with
check so rook captures on b3 queen to c5
with
check and now bishop to e3 pushing back
the
the queen queen to c for now with a
double attack on the e4 pawn and now
rook to f4 and here already you can see
that the position is really wild
uh black king still in the center of the
board white rooks on b3 and f4
so not something you see very often uh
and here
we reach a moment where uh for peter
lecko the first
official commentator on chess24 for
example said that uh maxime uh if
if he's to play such uh dangerous poison
lines that he should know
uh these kinds of positions that knights
to h5 is the way to play here
now i don't know if maxime knows this
and he just didn't think that it was
enough for
for a game against grand elios as of
course maxim is much higher rated
but here basically knight h5 is a draw
offer if you go knight h5
then you cannot go anywhere along the
fourth rank for example if rook to g4
just castles and already it's black
who's on the attack threatening queen to
f1 checkmate
and the black will now seize the
initiative so after knight h5 you're
going to have to go somewhere along the
f file
it doesn't really matter where rook f1
now you can repeat knight f6
again attack it goes here knight h5 and
and so on
so knights the h5 would have uh in fact
been a draw offer however maxine played
queen to e6 and he decided to keep
things sharp
uh offers the b7 pawn and decides to to
give up that pawn
castle and then play for something more
than a draw uh obviously
and uh here grendelius had to decide
whether to go after the pawn or not he
went for it
rook captures on b7 uh but this pawn
isn't as poisonous as the the
b2 pawn was so here white is basically
just
up upon and it's questionable how uh how
black
will go a deal about this so here at
maxine castles
and now h3 taking away the g4 square
from black's pieces
uh we have rook to b8 now uh forcing the
white rook to retreat from the
uh open b file rook to a7 going after
the pawn
and now rook to a8 uh here uh we have
traits captures captures and now
knight to d5 an excellent tricky knight
to d5 move
saying that uh capturing an e4 loses the
game on the spot
because of knight captures on e7 with
check queen captures and
knight queen to d5 with a nice triple
attack here of course you're gonna go
after the rook uh
king wherever uh but whatever you do
basically ends in checkmate here
uh your only move is king to h8 uh and
then just queen captures here you have
to give up the queen
uh again wherever doesn't really matter
queen characters will be checkmate
so knight d5 very tricky of course maxim
doesn't fall for that he goes rook to b8
and now comes c4 cementing that knight
on d5 and
again asking what do you do here here
probably capturing and d5 is the way to
go and then you continue playing this
position where white will always be a
little bit better
as he is still up material uh but maxime
decided to go bishop to d8 instead
and now what do you do here queen to f2
this is a a beautiful move because
you re-maneuver the queen saying it's
still not okay to capture this because
now if the knight moves rook to f8 is
checkmate
uh black's uh last move bishop d8 it
disconnected the rooks and the other
rook is now no longer
controlling the f8 square so queen to f2
preparing queen to g3
so wha what do you what do we have here
knight to d7
getting the knights to defend the f8
square and now comes
bishop to d4 just getting another piece
into the attack
we have bishop to g5 now attacking the
rook and
rook to f5 again uh you cannot capture
because the bishop is now hanging
so here maxine went bishop back to h8
and now
well you could go queen to g3 right away
first uh king to h2 uh grendelius says
uh
there's enough time to get my king to
to a safer position also not allow uh
rook b1 to come with
check at any point and it doesn't seem
like black has all that many useful
moves so here
rook the c8 was played by maxime and now
comes queen to g3
and now it's uh it's an extremely
dangerous position here
uh checkmate is being threatened not
right away the bishop covers it for the
moment but
that can easily change is just a it's
just a really really strong position for
for white so here g6 was played makes
sense you don't want to have g7 as a
target forever and also you can
start re-maneuvering your bishop you're
attacking the rook and so on
however the position is now completely
lost for black uh feel free to pause the
video and try to find the winning move
for
grendelius while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
move
uh it's not an easy one to find but none
of the moves in this game were easy to
find
so congratulations to everyone it's
queen to h for uh for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
now the thing is you're giving up your
rook here but grabbing the rook uh
is terrible for black if the rook is
captured first e
captures an f5 attacking the queen
saying that if you capture
97 check wins uh wins the queen here so
what you could do after captures is go
back with the queen
but now it's knight e7 check with a
double attack here
and after the king moves you just start
picking off everything knight captures
queen captures queen captures on h6
and let's say queen captures on c4 and
queen captures on d6
and it's a completely winning position
for white uh not much to do here
the knight is being threatened for
example king g8 f6 is coming and there's
just
there's just not nothing for black to do
here so
uh accepting the rook uh doesn't work
here so here
bishop the f8 was played and now comes
rook to f6 another brilliant idea rook
to f6 now
attacking the queen and offering a full
rook but the rook cannot be captured
because if captures then comes captures
with
check and you either have to give up the
queen or you go for a nice king walk but
then just captures with
check the king has nowhere to go both of
these squares are covered
you have to block and then the amazing
knight the g4
now threatening uh queen captures queen
cat
wow queen captures on g7 and after this
is defended then of course knight h6
check now nicely connects with the real
king f8
and now uh you just start picking off
everything uh bishop captures on g7 with
check row captures you're gonna play
queen to h8 to check
force the king away from the defense of
the rook or uh better yet
black might give up the rook here knight
captures queen captures and now you can
even go into a king and pawn end game uh
you're up uh up
pawns uh europe two pawns of course a
completely winning king and
in the game for white so after rook to
f6 maxime has to decline this
queen to e8 once again and now rook
cactus and f8
dealing the final blow king queen
captures and now
knight to e7 with check king to f7
knight captures on c8 and it was in this
position animal 35 that maxine bashar
lagrav resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh you obviously have to take back the
the knight if the game
uh continues uh but after that it just
queen captures on h7
the the this is covered so you have to
move away and then comes the queen
captures on g6 with the check
now you're already up three pawns these
these are two connected pass pawns so
it's a completely winning position for
white
so after knight captures nc8 maxim
resigned and another brilliant victory
for niels grandelius who is on a great
way to
go back to that first place to where he
came from and
we'll see if he can take solo lead in
the tournament after round five as
all of the other games are still running
so really amazing to see
uh the the master of the sicilian
defense uh
and even better the the master of the
night or maxine martial grav being taken
down like this
so who knows what happened here maybe
it's lakos uh that uh maxim didn't go
for that
uh uh after this worked for move uh that
knights the h5 idea just forcing a draw
uh or maybe maxim knew of about this and
he is
you know a lot higher rated than
grindelwa so maybe he thought that he
can sacrifice the b7 pawn to keep the
game alive
uh but the grand delus after that moment
just played a perfect game he he found
everything absolutely everything
and he was able to take down the leader
of the candidates tournament so great
job by the swedish grandmaster i hope
you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank scott rooks
alex mcguire jeffrey r look
uh anthony randazzo and simon johansson
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the tata still checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day